bentornato a Capire l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico, mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico dell'educazione presso IBM
Quantum. Questa è la lezione numero 14 della serie ed è la seconda lezione della quarta unità, che tratta la correzione degli errori quantistici.
Nella lezione precedente abbiamo dato uno sguardo iniziale alla correzione degli errori quantistici, incluso il codice Shore a nove qubit, che stabilisce che
la correzione degli errori quantistici è possibile in teoria. Abbiamo anche discusso la discretizzazione degli errori, che ci permette
di correggere errori quantistici arbitrari sui qubit proiettandoli efficacemente su flip di bit e flip di fase.
In questa lezione discuteremo il formalismo degli stabilizzatori, uno strumento matematico attraverso il quale possiamo
specificare e analizzare un'ampia classe di codici di correzione degli errori quantistici noti come codici stabilizzatori. Questo include il codice Shore a 9 qubit
insieme a molti altri esempi, inclusi codici che potrebbero essere molto più adatti ai dispositivi di calcolo quantistico reali
rispetto al codice Shore. Non tutti i codici di correzione degli errori quantistici sono codici stabilizzatori, ma molti lo sono,
inclusi tutti gli esempi che vedremo in questa serie. Esistono certamente codici di correzione degli errori quantistici interessanti e potenzialmente utili
che non sono codici stabilizzatori, ma tendono ad essere piuttosto più complicati e in ogni caso non c'è
dubbio che il formalismo degli stabilizzatori sia una pietra angolare nella fondazione della correzione degli errori quantistici, e noi
ci baseremo ampiamente su di esso per il resto dell'unità. Ecco una breve panoramica della lezione: inizieremo con una breve discussione
delle matrici di Pauli e dei prodotti tensoriali di matrici di Pauli, che possono rappresentare sia operazioni sui qubit sia
misurazioni dei qubit, come spiegherò, e in questo contesto le chiamiamo spesso osservabili. Torneremo poi a osservare
il codice a ripetizione e vedremo come possiamo descriverlo tramite operazioni e osservabili di Pauli, il che ci informerà
e porterà a una discussione generale dei codici stabilizzatori, inclusi diversi esempi, proprietà di base dei codici stabilizzatori
e come possiamo svolgere i compiti fondamentali di codifica, rilevamento degli errori e correzione degli
errori. Inizieremo la lezione con una breve discussione delle operazioni di Pauli, principalmente per preparare il terreno al
formalismo degli stabilizzatori, ma anche per osservare alcuni fatti chiave e stabilire la terminologia di base. Prima di tutto, ecco le matrici di Pauli,
inclusa la matrice identità 2x2 e le tre matrici di Pauli non-identità, che denoteremo con
X maiuscola, Y e Z per il resto della serie. Tutte e quattro queste matrici sono sia unitarie che hermitiane, e possiamo
identificarle con operazioni su un qubit, incluse operazioni che potremmo scegliere di eseguire nonché errori, come
abbiamo discusso nella lezione precedente. Le matrici di Pauli non-identità X, Y e Z anticommutano tra loro,
il che significa che XY è uguale a -1 * YX, XZ è uguale a meno ZX e YZ è uguale
a meno ZY, e puoi facilmente verificare queste relazioni moltiplicando le matrici. Queste relazioni di anticommutazione
sono molto semplici ma sono di fondamentale importanza nel formalismo degli stabilizzatori e altrove. In particolare,
come vedremo, questi segni meno che compaiono quando scambiamo l'ordine di due diverse matrici di Pauli non-identità in un prodotto corrispondono precisamente al
rilevamento degli errori nel formalismo degli stabilizzatori. Abbiamo anche le regole di moltiplicazione elencate qui: ogni
matrice di Pauli è il proprio inverso, il che è coerente con il fatto che sono sia unitarie che hermitiane, e se moltiplichi due diverse matrici di Pauli non-identità
otterrai sempre più o meno I moltiplicato per la rimanente matrice di Pauli non-identità.
In particolare, a meno di una fase globale, Y è equivalente a X moltiplicato Z, il che spiega la nostra attenzione agli errori X e Z nella
correzione degli errori quantistici. X rappresenta un flip di bit, Z rappresenta un flip di fase, e quindi a meno di una fase globale Y rappresenta
entrambi questi errori che si verificano sullo stesso qubit. Queste quattro matrici rappresentano tutte
operazioni, errori o l'assenza di un errore su un singolo qubit, ma è spesso conveniente unirle con il prodotto tensoriale
per eseguire operazioni o errori su più qubit. Come punto di terminologia, ogni volta che ci riferiamo a un'operazione di Pauli a N qubit
intendiamo un prodotto tensoriale di qualsiasi n matrici di Pauli, come negli esempi mostrati
qui. È anche comune usare il termine operazione di Pauli quando è presente una fase globale, ma per mantenere le cose il più semplici possibile
userò il termine operazione di Pauli per indicare semplicemente un prodotto tensoriale di matrici di Pauli. Il peso di un'operazione di Pauli a N qubit
è semplicemente il numero di matrici di Pauli non-identità nel prodotto tensoriale. Ad esempio, il prodotto tensoriale
n-fold della matrice identità 2x2 con se stessa è un'operazione di Pauli di peso zero, un prodotto tensoriale di due matrici Pauli X
e un gruppo di matrici identità ha peso due, e così via. Intuitivamente, il peso di un'operazione di Pauli a N
qubit è il numero di qubit su cui agisce in modo non banale, ed è tipico che i codici di correzione degli errori quantistici siano
progettati in modo da poter rilevare e correggere errori rappresentati da operazioni di Pauli fino a un certo peso. Possiamo
pensare alle operazioni di Pauli in vari modi, incluso come operazioni eseguite intenzionalmente dai gate quantistici nonché
come errori, e vedremo presto che le operazioni di Pauli possono descrivere misurazioni. A volte è anche utile
pensare alle operazioni di Pauli come generatori di certi insiemi in senso algebrico, che potresti riconoscere
se hai familiarità con la teoria dei gruppi. Se non conosci la teoria dei gruppi, va bene: non è davvero essenziale
per questa lezione, ma se sei interessato a studiare la correzione degli errori quantistici in modo più approfondito, potresti trovare che alcune
nozioni di teoria dei gruppi siano molto utili a tale scopo. Ad ogni modo, supponiamo che P1 fino a PR siano operazioni di Pauli a N qubit:
P1 è un'operazione di Pauli a N qubit, P2 è un'operazione di Pauli a N qubit, e così via. Quando ci riferiamo all'insieme generato da
P1 fino a PR, intendiamo l'insieme di tutte le matrici che possiamo ottenere moltiplicando queste matrici tra loro
in qualsiasi combinazione e in qualsiasi ordine scegliamo, prendendo ciascuna quante volte vogliamo. Vedremo alcuni esempi tra poco,
ma prima lasciatemi menzionare la notazione che usiamo per denotare questo insieme: l'insieme generato da P1 fino a PR
si scrive P1 fino a PR separati da virgole all'interno di parentesi angolari. Sembra quasi che potremmo confondere
questa notazione con la notazione di Dirac, ma in genere non accade, e questa è la notazione tradizionale nella teoria dei
gruppi. Ecco un esempio dell'insieme generato da X, Y e Z, quindi N è uguale a uno in questo esempio perché non ci sono
prodotti tensoriali e prendiamo tutte e tre le matrici di Pauli non-identità come generatori. Si scopre che ci sono
16 matrici che possono essere generate formando prodotti che includono queste tre matrici, e puoi ragionarci
attraverso le regole di moltiplicazione che abbiamo visto prima. Nello specifico possiamo ovviamente ottenere X, Y e Z, nonché l'identità,
e in effetti possiamo anche ottenere qualsiasi di queste quattro matrici moltiplicate per i, 1 o per i negativo, e questo è
tutto. Questo insieme è comunemente noto come gruppo di Pauli. Potremmo anche considerare l'insieme
generato solo da X e Z, e in questo caso otteniamo la metà del gruppo di Pauli.
E un ultimo esempio, almeno per ora: possiamo considerare l'insieme generato da X tensore X e Z tensore Z, quindi N è uguale a
due in questo caso, e otteniamo solo quattro elementi questa volta, grazie al fatto che X tensore X e Z tensore Z
commutano tra loro. Le matrici di Pauli e le operazioni di Pauli a N qubit in generale descrivono
operazioni unitarie, siano esse errori o intenzionali, ma descrivono anche
misurazioni. Per essere più precisi, partendo solo dalle tre matrici di Pauli non-identità, possiamo associare ciascuna di queste
matrici a una misurazione proiettiva definita in termini dei suoi autovalori e autovettori, e qui sullo schermo abbiamo
le decomposizioni spettrali di queste matrici che aiuteranno a chiarire tutto questo. In sostanza, quando ci riferiamo a una misurazione X,
una misurazione Y o una misurazione Z, intendiamo la misurazione proiettiva definita dalle proiezioni
sugli autospazi di queste matrici, e comunemente pensiamo agli autovalori come ai corrispondenti
risultati di misurazione. Ad esempio, una misurazione X è una misurazione rispetto alla base più/meno
di un qubit, o in alternativa possiamo descriverla tramite l'insieme contenente le proiezioni |+⟩⟨+| e
|−⟩⟨−|. Una misurazione Z, d'altra parte, non è altro che una misurazione nella base standard,
anche se, come ho detto, a volte identifichiamo gli autovalori con i risultati di misurazione, e se lo facciamo
allora i risultati sono più uno e meno uno invece di 0 e 1 rispettivamente. Possiamo in effetti fare qualcosa di
simile per matrici hermitiane arbitrarie, e il termine osservabile è comunemente usato in questa situazione. Per le matrici di Pauli
e le operazioni di Pauli a N qubit in generale, possiamo eseguire tali misurazioni in modo non distruttivo usando
la stima di fase. Solo per assicurarmi che questo diagramma sia chiaro: qui stiamo eseguendo le misurazioni in modo non distruttivo sul
qubit in alto, mentre il qubit in basso viene sempre inizializzato in uno stato più, ovvero un Hadamard applicato a uno
stato zero, perché è così che funziona la stima di fase. Nota che poiché gli autovalori
sono solo più uno e meno uno in questo caso, abbiamo bisogno di un solo qubit di controllo, che è il qubit in basso in questo
diagramma. Averne più di uno sarebbe solo uno spreco, perché c'è solo un bit di precisione di cui preoccuparsi: l'autovalore
è o più uno o meno uno, e la misurazione è già perfetta così com'è. Il risultato di questa misurazione,
cioè la misurazione nella base standard nel circuit, sarà zero per il risultato con autovalore più uno,
che corrisponde allo stato più nel caso di un'osservabile X, e il risultato è uno per l'autovalore meno uno
o lo stato meno in questo caso. Tutto ciò che ho appena detto si estende naturalmente alle operazioni di Pauli a N qubit,
a condizione che teniamo presente che quando pensiamo a un'osservabile stiamo parlando di misurare gli autovalori,
non di misurare rispetto a una base di autovettori. Ad esempio, considera l'operazione di Pauli a due
qubit Z tensore Z: ancora una volta ci sono due autovalori, più uno e meno uno, quindi la
misurazione è descritta da due proiezioni. Nota in particolare che la misurazione che associamo a
questa osservabile non è la stessa cosa di misurare entrambi i qubit con una misurazione Z, ovvero una misurazione nella base standard, ma è piuttosto una misurazione proiettiva a due
risultati in cui le proiezioni vanno sugli spazi generati da tutti i vettori propri corrispondenti a
ciascuno dei due autovalori più uno e meno uno. Un altro modo di pensarci è che gli autovalori di un prodotto
tensoriale sono prodotti degli autovalori delle singole matrici di cui stiamo prendendo il prodotto tensoriale, e
poiché negativo 1 moltiplicato per negativo 1 è uguale a positivo 1 moltiplicato per positivo 1, ad esempio, questa misurazione non
distingue tra 00 e 11. Quindi se misurassimo uno stato di Bell Φ+ con la misurazione
descritta da questa osservabile, saremmo certi di ottenere il risultato corrispondente all'autovalore più uno
e lo stato rimarrebbe invariato, invece di collassare su 00 o 11, che è quello che accadrebbe se
eseguissimo le misurazioni nella base standard sui due qubit. Quindi una misurazione Z tensore Z non è
la stessa cosa di eseguire due misurazioni Z indipendentemente, ma possiamo in effetti eseguire misurazioni come questa usando la stima di
fase esattamente nello stesso modo di prima, usando un singolo qubit di controllo come mostrato nel diagramma del circuit, che
si generalizza a qualsiasi operazione di Pauli a N qubit al posto di Z tensore Z. Quando abbiamo solo matrici Pauli Z,
possiamo semplificare il circuit in questo modo, e ciò che questo rivela, ed è anche evidente dalle proiezioni che definiscono
la misurazione, è che eseguire una misurazione Z tensore Z su due qubit equivale a misurare la loro parità
in termini della base standard, e questo si generalizza al prodotto tensoriale di qualsiasi numero di matrici Pauli Z.
Successivamente daremo un secondo sguardo al codice a ripetizione a tre bit, questa volta formulandolo in termini di operazioni di Pauli.
Questo sarà il nostro primo, abbastanza semplice, esempio di codice stabilizzatore, e discuteremo come generalizzare questo
concetto tra poco, ma è utile vedere come funziona in questo caso semplice prima. Ricorda che quando applichiamo il
codice a ripetizione a 3 bit ai qubit, codifichiamo un dato stato di qubit Alpha |0⟩ + beta |1⟩ come Alpha |000⟩ + beta |111⟩,
e per comodità chiameremo questa codifica a tre qubit Psi. Quindi per definizione Psi è una codifica valida a tre qubit
di uno stato di qubit. Ma se vogliamo verificarlo, è sufficiente controllare che le seguenti due equazioni siano vere: la
prima equazione afferma che applicare operazioni Z ai due qubit più a sinistra di Psi non fa nulla a Psi, ovvero Psi
è un autovettore di Z tensore Z tensore identità, o semplicemente ZZ-identità, con autovalore uno. La seconda
equazione è simile eccetto che le operazioni Z vengono applicate ai due qubit più a destra. L'idea è che se pensiamo a Psi
come combinazione lineare di stati della base standard, la prima equazione implica che possiamo avere coefficienti non nulli solo per stati della base standard
in cui i due bit più a sinistra hanno parità pari, ovvero sono uguali, e la seconda equazione implica che possiamo avere
coefficienti non nulli solo per stati della base standard in cui i due bit più a destra hanno parità pari. Un altro modo di pensarci
è di vedere queste due operazioni di Pauli come osservabili e, se misurassimo queste due osservabili usando il
circuit semplificato di cui ho appena parlato, saremmo certi di ottenere un risultato di misurazione corrispondente agli autovalori più uno
perché Psi è un autovettore di entrambe le osservabili con autovalore uno. Ma questa versione semplificata del circuit combinato
per misurare indipendentemente le osservabili non è altro che il nostro circuit di controllo di parità per il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit,
e quindi vediamo che le nostre due equazioni insieme sono equivalenti al circuit di controllo di parità che produce 00,
che è la sindrome che indica che non sono stati rilevati errori. Le operazioni di Pauli a tre qubit
ZZ-identità e identità-ZZ sono chiamate generatori dello stabilizzatore per questo codice, e lo stabilizzatore del codice è l'insieme
generato dai generatori dello stabilizzatore. Questo insieme, lo stabilizzatore, è un oggetto matematico fondamentalmente importante
associato a questo codice, e discuteremo ulteriormente il ruolo che svolge man mano che la lezione continua. Per ora
voglio solo sottolineare che avremmo potuto fare una scelta diversa per i generatori: ad esempio, avremmo potuto selezionare Z-identità-Z al posto di uno
dei generatori che abbiamo selezionato, e il codice e lo stabilizzatore sarebbero stati esattamente gli stessi. Considereremo poi il rilevamento dei flip di bit
per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit, concentrandoci sulle interazioni e le relazioni tra le operazioni di Pauli
coinvolte, cioè i generatori dello stabilizzatore e gli errori stessi. Supponiamo che abbiamo codificato un
qubit usando il codice a ripetizione a tre bit e si verifica un errore di flip di bit sul qubit più a sinistra: questo fa sì che il nostro stato Psi venga
trasformato dall'azione di un'operazione X, ovvero un errore X sul qubit più a sinistra. Come sappiamo già, possiamo rilevare
questo errore eseguendo i controlli di parità per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit, oppure equivalentemente possiamo misurare
la codifica in modo non distruttivo trattando i generatori dello stabilizzatore come osservabili. Cominciamo con il primo
generatore dello stabilizzatore e vediamo cosa succede. Il nostro stato è stato influenzato da un errore X e vorremmo capire
come la misurazione del generatore dello stabilizzatore come osservabile viene influenzata da questo errore. X e Z anticommutano,
mentre tutto commuta con la matrice identità, quindi ne consegue che ZZ-identità anticommuta con X-identità-
identità, quindi otteniamo un segno meno quando l'ordine viene cambiato. Sappiamo anche che ZZ-identità non fa nulla a Psi
perché Psi è una codifica valida di un qubit, e le codifiche valide sono sempre autovettori di più uno di entrambi i generatori dello
stabilizzatore. Rimane X-identità-identità applicato a Psi negativo, e quindi X-identità-identità applicato a
Psi è un autovettore di ZZ-identità con autovalore negativo uno. Possiamo fare qualcosa di simile
con il secondo generatore dello stabilizzatore, ma questa volta l'errore commuta con il generatore dello stabilizzatore e quindi il nostro
stato corrotto è di nuovo un autovettore del generatore dello stabilizzatore, ma questa volta l'autovalore è positivo
uno. Quindi il nostro stato corrotto è un autovettore di entrambi i generatori dello stabilizzatore e se l'autovalore è più uno o
meno uno è determinato dal fatto che l'errore commuti o anticommuti con ciascun generatore dello stabilizzatore. Per il primo
generatore l'errore e il generatore dello stabilizzatore anticommutano, e per il secondo commutano. Sarà sempre l'uno o l'altro, perché due qualsiasi
operazioni di Pauli o commutano o anticommutano. Nel frattempo, lo stato effettivo Psi non svolge davvero un ruolo importante
qui, tranne per il fatto che i generatori dello stabilizzatore agiscono banalmente su questo stato. Quindi quando stiamo pensando al
rilevamento degli errori non dobbiamo preoccuparci dello specifico stato codificato: tutto ciò che conta è se l'errore commuta o anticommuta
con ciascun generatore dello stabilizzatore. Creiamo quindi una tabella con una riga per ciascun generatore dello stabilizzatore
e una colonna per ciascun errore. Qui ho incluso solo gli errori corrispondenti a un singolo flip di bit
nonché nessun errore, indicato dall'identità tensorializzata con se stessa tre volte. Potremmo aggiungere altre colonne per altri errori se volessimo,
ma per ora ci concentreremo solo su questi errori. Il valore nella tabella è più uno o meno uno a seconda
che l'errore e il generatore dello stabilizzatore commutino o anticommutino. Quindi per ogni errore nella tabella possiamo guardare
la colonna corrispondente per vedere come quell'errore trasformerà qualsiasi codifica data in un autovettore di più uno o meno uno
di ciascun generatore dello stabilizzatore. Queste colonne corrispondono precisamente alla sindrome che otterremmo dai
controlli di parità, che sono equivalenti alle misurazioni non distruttive dei generatori dello stabilizzatore come
osservabili. Naturalmente le voci di questa tabella sono più uno e meno uno invece di zero e uno rispettivamente,
e se preferisci puoi pensare alle sindromi come alle corrispondenti stringhe binarie invece che alle colonne di più uno e meno uno, ma c'è una
corrispondenza diretta. E solo per rendere più chiara e diretta la connessione tra le sindromi e gli autovalori,
mi riferirò a questi vettori di più uno e meno uno come sindromi, come prima. Le sindromi ci dicono
qualcosa su qualsiasi errore si sia verificato e, in particolare, se sappiamo che si è verificato uno di questi quattro possibili errori,
la sindrome ci indica quale era, e possiamo correggerlo applicando di nuovo l'errore se
scegliamo. Poi dirò solo un po' di più sulle sindromi e in particolare esamineremo più da vicino
i loro aspetti algebrici. Le nostre codifiche sono stati a tre qubit, quindi sono vettori unitari in uno
spazio vettoriale complesso a otto dimensioni, e ciò che fanno le quattro possibili sindromi è dividere questo spazio a otto dimensioni
in quattro sottospazi bidimensionali, nel senso che i vettori in uno qualsiasi di questi sottospazi ci daranno sempre la stessa
sindrome. In maggior dettaglio, questo diagramma illustra come lo spazio a otto dimensioni è suddiviso:
ciascun generatore dello stabilizzatore divide lo spazio in due sottospazi di uguale dimensione, cioè lo spazio degli autovettori di più uno
e lo spazio degli autovettori di meno uno. Ad esempio, gli autovettori di più uno di ZZ-identità sono combinazioni lineari
di stati della base standard in cui i due bit più a sinistra hanno parità pari, e gli autovettori di meno uno sono combinazioni lineari
di stati della base standard in cui i due bit più a sinistra hanno parità dispari. La situazione è simile per
l'altro generatore dello stabilizzatore, tranne che si tratta dei due bit più a destra anziché dei due più a sinistra. Quindi questi quattro sottospazi sono facili da
descrivere in questo caso, grazie al fatto che questo è un codice molto semplice. In particolare, il sottospazio
corrispondente alla sindrome più uno più uno è lo spazio generato da |000⟩ e |111⟩, che è lo spazio delle codifiche valide,
chiamato spazio del codice. In generale gli spazi sono generati dagli stati della base standard
mostrati nei quadrati corrispondenti, anche se non è necessariamente così chiaro o facile vedere questo. Le sindromi
partizionano anche tutte le operazioni di Pauli a tre qubit, che rappresentano i possibili errori di Pauli, in quattro collezioni di uguale dimensione
a seconda di quale sindrome quell'errore causerebbe. Ad esempio, qualsiasi operazione di Pauli
che commuta con entrambi i generatori dello stabilizzatore produce la sindrome più1 più1, e tra le 64 possibili operazioni di Pauli a tre
qubit ce ne sono esattamente 16 in questa categoria, incluse le tre menzionate sullo schermo, e lo stesso vale per le altre tre
Questo non è ovvio ma è vero, e questa proprietà fondamentale che le sindromi partizionano sia lo spazio degli stati
in cui vivono le codifiche sia tutti i possibili errori di Pauli nello spazio in pezzi di uguale dimensione è qualcosa che è
vero in generale per i codici stabilizzatori, che definiremo presto con precisione. Anche se è principalmente solo un inciso,
vale la pena menzionare che le operazioni di Pauli che commutano con entrambi i generatori dello stabilizzatore, ovvero
le operazioni di Pauli che producono la sindrome più1 più1 ma non sono esse stesse proporzionali a elementi dello stabilizzatore, si comportano proprio come
singole operazioni di Pauli sul qubit logico che abbiamo codificato. Ad esempio, XXX commuta con
entrambi i generatori dello stabilizzatore ma non è proporzionale a nessun elemento dello stabilizzatore, ed è chiaro se
ci pensi un momento che l'effetto che questa operazione ha su una codifica è equivalente a un gate X sul
qubit logico codificato, e ancora una volta questo è qualcosa che si generalizza a tutti i codici stabilizzatori. È ora il momento di definire i codici stabilizzatori
in generale, e il modo in cui funziona è che facciamo qualcosa di completamente analogo a ciò che abbiamo appena discusso per
il codice a ripetizione a tre bit, tranne che scegliamo generatori dello stabilizzatore diversi, che chiameremo tutti P1
fino a PR ai fini di questa spiegazione. Questi generatori dello stabilizzatore devono essere tutti operazioni di Pauli a N qubit,
dove N è il numero di qubit usati per la codifica, e non possiamo scegliere un insieme qualsiasi di generatori dello stabilizzatore: questi
devono soddisfare alcune condizioni di base. Prima di tutto, i generatori dello stabilizzatore devono commutare tutti tra
loro. Nel caso del codice a ripetizione a tre bit non ci siamo preoccupati di notarlo, ma è semplice osservare che ZZ-identità e identità-
ZZ commutano effettivamente perché Z commuta con se stesso e tutto commuta con l'
identità. Per i codici stabilizzatori con generatori dello stabilizzatore più complicati, invece, inclusi codici in cui abbiamo
sia X che Z che appaiono nei generatori dello stabilizzatore, questa è una condizione importante che deve essere
verificata. Un modo di pensare alla necessità di questa condizione è che tratteremo i generatori dello stabilizzatore come osservabili, e richiedendo che
commutino tutti ci assicuriamo che l'ordine in cui eseguiamo queste misurazioni non
abbia importanza. Secondo, i generatori dello stabilizzatore devono formare un cosiddetto insieme generatore minimale, il che significa che se ne rimuovessimo uno qualsiasi
otterremmo uno stabilizzatore più piccolo, e un modo per esprimere questo matematicamente è mostrato qui sullo
schermo. In senso stretto questa condizione non è davvero essenziale al modo in cui un codice stabilizzatore funziona in senso operativo,
e a volte ha senso pensare a insiemi generatori non minimali, come vedremo nella prossima lezione. Ma
ai fini dell'analisi dei codici stabilizzatori e della spiegazione delle loro proprietà, assumeremo che questa condizione sia in
atto. Fondamentalmente questa condizione garantisce che ogni osservabile che misuriamo per ottenere la sindrome stia aggiungendo
informazioni sugli eventuali errori invece di essere ridondante e fornire risultati che potrebbero essere facilmente dedotti dagli altri generatori dello stabilizzatore come
osservabili. E infine deve essere il caso che almeno un vettore non nullo sia fissato da tutti
i generatori dello stabilizzatore, e ciò risulta essere equivalente a richiedere che meno uno volte l'identità su N qubit non sia
contenuto nello stabilizzatore. Non è ovvio, ma il punto è che è possibile scegliere un insieme generatore minimale
di operazioni di Pauli a N qubit che commutano tutte tra loro, eppure nessun vettore è simultaneamente un autovettore di più uno
di tutte le matrici, e non vogliamo preoccuparci di questa possibilità perché i codici in cui non ci sono codifiche valide non sono
interessanti. Questi sono quindi i requisiti sui generatori dello stabilizzatore per un codice stabilizzatore, e se abbiamo un insieme di generatori che
soddisfano queste condizioni, allora abbiamo un codice stabilizzatore valido e possiamo considerarne le proprietà. Esistono molti
codici stabilizzatori diversi con varie proprietà che li rendono interessanti o meno, ma tutti soddisfano alcune proprietà di base
che ricordano quelle già osservate per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit.
Daremo presto un'occhiata ad alcuni esempi, ma prima lasciami menzionare che quando ci riferiamo allo spazio del codice di un codice stabilizzatore intendiamo il sottospazio
dello spazio degli stati a N qubit che include ogni vettore che è simultaneamente un autovettore di più uno di ognuno dei
generatori dello stabilizzatore. Questo è il sottospazio dello spazio degli stati a N qubit in cui vivono le codifiche valide, e avremo altro da
dire su questo sottospazio man mano che la lezione continua. Vediamo ora alcuni esempi di codici stabilizzatori.
Ecco l'esempio che abbiamo già discusso: il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit ordinario. Possiamo anche esprimere la
versione modificata di quel codice della lezione precedente, che può rilevare un flip di fase invece di un flip di bit, come codice stabilizzatore, come mostrato
qui. Questa volta i generatori dello stabilizzatore misurano osservabili XX invece di osservabili ZZ, quindi questi sono fondamentalmente
controlli di parità nella base più/meno invece che nella base standard. In entrambi i casi possiamo
vedere immediatamente che abbiamo un codice stabilizzatore valido perché i generatori dello stabilizzatore commutano, questi sono insiemi generatori
minimali e lo spazio del codice è non banale come sappiamo già. Ma possiamo anche vedere abbastanza chiaramente che non
possiamo generare meno uno moltiplicato per l'identità. Ed ecco il codice Shore a 9 qubit, che è anche un codice stabilizzatore
espresso tramite generatori dello stabilizzatore. In questo caso abbiamo fondamentalmente tre copie del codice a ripetizione a tre
bit, una per ciascuno dei tre blocchi di tre qubit, nonché gli ultimi due generatori dello stabilizzatore che
hanno una forma che ricorda il circuit che abbiamo visto nella lezione precedente per rilevare i flip di fase per questo
codice. Un altro modo di pensare a questi ultimi due generatori dello stabilizzatore è che hanno esattamente la stessa forma che
abbiamo per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit per i flip di fase, tranne che sostituiamo XXX a X, e la ragione per
questo è che XXX corrisponde a un'operazione X sul qubit logico codificato usando il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit. Ma
questo è un inciso e non è qualcosa di cui preoccuparsi adesso. Nel caso non fosse chiaro, esamineremo presto
altri esempi. Ma prima, lasciami menzionare che le persone spesso omettono i simboli del prodotto tensoriale quando descrivono i codici stabilizzatori perché tende a
renderli più facili da leggere. Ecco come appaiono questi codici senza i simboli del prodotto tensoriale:
ma naturalmente questi sono prodotti tensoriali e non prodotti matriciali ordinari; ad esempio, stiamo solo omettendo i simboli del prodotto tensoriale in modo che sia meno
complicato e i pattern siano più chiari. Ecco un altro esempio: si chiama
codice Steane a 7 qubit e ha alcune caratteristiche piuttosto notevoli. Torneremo su questo
di tanto in tanto nelle lezioni rimanenti dell'unità, ma per ora possiamo semplicemente verificare che sia un codice stabilizzatore valido.
In particolare, i primi tre generatori dello stabilizzatore commutano chiaramente tra loro perché Z commuta con
se stesso e l'identità commuta con tutto, e la situazione è simile per gli ultimi tre. Rimane quindi da
verificare che se prendiamo uno dei generatori Z dello stabilizzatore e uno dei generatori X dello stabilizzatore, allora commutino,
ed è abbastanza semplice esaminare le nove possibili coppie per verificare che in tutti questi casi avremo sempre
una X e una Z che si trovano nella stessa posizione un numero pari di volte, quindi i due generatori commutano proprio
come XX e ZZ commutano. È un insieme generatore minimale e ha uno spazio del codice non banale, ma
non proverò ad argomentarlo in questo video; lo lascio a te se vuoi pensarci. Il codice Steane a 7 qubit è simile
al codice Shore a 9 qubit nel senso che codifica un singolo qubit e permette la correzione di un errore arbitrario su un qubit, ma richiede solo
sette qubit invece di nove. Questo non è il numero minimo di qubit richiesto per un codice correttore di errori per
codificare un qubit e correggere un errore arbitrario su un singolo qubit. Ecco un codice stabilizzatore
chiamato semplicemente codice a cinque qubit, che codifica anche un singolo qubit e può correggere qualsiasi errore su un singolo qubit,
e cinque è il numero minimo di qubit per cui questo è possibile. Ecco un altro esempio di
codice stabilizzatore, anche se non è proprio un codice nel senso stretto del termine, dato che lo spazio del codice è
monodimensionale. In particolare, lo spazio del codice per questo codice è lo spazio generato da un ebit, ovvero uno stato di Bell Φ+,
quindi non puoi effettivamente codificare nessun qubit usando questo codice, ma è comunque un codice stabilizzatore valido in cui lo spazio del codice
è monodimensionale. Ed è possibile fare qualcosa di simile per uno stato
GHZ. Questi sono dunque alcuni esempi di codici stabilizzatori, e vedremo infiniti altri esempi nella
prossima lezione. Supponiamo di avere un codice stabilizzatore: una domanda naturale da porsi
è, forse la prima che viene in mente, quanti qubit codifica? Quella domanda ha una risposta molto semplice,
e per spiegarla siamo precisi sul codice stabilizzatore considerato. Abbiamo R generatori dello stabilizzatore a N qubit
P1 fino a PR che soddisfano i tre requisiti che ho menzionato in precedenza, cioè che i
generatori dello stabilizzatore commutino tutti tra loro, che sia un insieme generatore minimale quindi non otterremmo lo stesso
stabilizzatore se rimuovessimo uno dei generatori, e che ci sia almeno un vettore non nullo nello spazio del codice.
Come indica il teorema mostrato sullo schermo, deve allora essere che lo spazio del codice del codice stabilizzatore ha
dimensione 2 alla N meno R, ovvero possiamo codificare N
meno R qubit usando questo codice. Intuitivamente abbiamo N qubit nelle nostre codifiche e ciascun
generatore dello stabilizzatore rimuove effettivamente un qubit in termini di quanti qubit possiamo codificare.
Questo teorema non è troppo difficile da dimostrare e te ne mostrerò una dimostrazione tra un momento, ma prima esamineremo solo
pochi esempi. Partendo dal codice a ripetizione a 3 bit ordinario, abbiamo tre qubit nelle nostre
codifiche quindi N è uguale a tre, e ci sono R uguale a 2 generatori dello stabilizzatore, quindi possiamo codificare uno
qubit usando questo codice. Nota che questo non riguarda quali errori possano essere rilevati o
corretti: questo è un altro discorso. Questa è solo un'affermazione sulla dimensione dello spazio del codice.
Per un altro esempio, considera il codice a cinque qubit: qui abbiamo cinque qubit e quattro
generatori dello stabilizzatore, quindi ancora una volta lo spazio del codice ha dimensione due, il che significa che possiamo codificare un qubit usando questo
codice. E un altro esempio per ora: per il codice stabilizzatore ebit abbiamo due qubit e due generatori dello stabilizzatore, quindi
lo spazio del codice è monodimensionale, e come ho menzionato in precedenza è lo spazio generato dallo stato di Bell Φ+.
Vedremo altri esempi man mano che andiamo avanti, inclusi codici in cui possiamo codificare più di un qubit, ma per ora
vediamo come possiamo dimostrare il teorema. La prima cosa che dobbiamo osservare è che poiché i generatori dello stabilizzatore
commutano e formano un insieme generatore minimale e poiché ogni operazione di Pauli è il proprio inverso, ogni
elemento dello stabilizzatore può essere espresso in modo unico come prodotto in cui eleviamo ciascun generatore dello stabilizzatore
PK alla potenza AK dove ciascun AK è o zero o uno, e poi moltiplichiamo i risultati
insieme. Un altro modo per dirlo è che otteniamo ogni elemento dello stabilizzatore moltiplicando insieme un sottoinsieme dei
generatori dello stabilizzatore, e non otteniamo mai lo stesso elemento dello stabilizzatore da sottoinsiemi diversi. Una cosa che
questo implica è che l'unico modo per esprimere l'operazione identità a N qubit in questo modo è prendere tutte le potenze uguali a
zero. Definiamo poi Pi_K come la proiezione sullo spazio degli autovettori di più uno di PK per ogni K da 1 a R, e c'è
una formula semplice per questa proiezione: possiamo semplicemente calcolare la media di PK con l'identità su N qubit, che lascia efficacemente gli autovalori di più uno
invariati e porta a zero tutti gli autovalori di meno uno.
Ora, lo spazio del codice è definito come l'insieme di tutti i vettori che sono simultaneamente autovettori di più uno di tutti
i generatori dello stabilizzatore. Dato che i generatori dello stabilizzatore commutano, anche le proiezioni devono commutare, e ciò
implica che il prodotto di queste proiezioni è anch'esso una proiezione, in particolare è la proiezione sul
intersezione dei sottospazi sui quali le singole proiezioni proiettano, ovvero è la proiezione sullo
spazio del codice. Possiamo espandere questo prodotto e ciò che otteniamo è la media su ogni
elemento dello stabilizzatore. E infine, poiché la dimensione di qualsiasi sottospazio è uguale alla
traccia della proiezione su quel sottospazio, troviamo che la dimensione dello spazio del codice è la media delle tracce sugli elementi dello
stabilizzatore. Ma ad eccezione dell'operazione identità a N qubit, tutti gli elementi dello stabilizzatore devono avere
traccia uguale a zero, perché le tre matrici di Pauli non-identità hanno tutte traccia uguale a zero. La traccia dell'operazione identità a N qubit
è 2 alla N, e quindi troviamo che la dimensione dello spazio del codice è 2 alla N meno R, il che dimostra il
teorema. Poi dirò solo un po' su come i qubit possono essere codificati usando codici stabilizzatori, ma per farlo dobbiamo prima
introdurre le operazioni di Clifford. Le operazioni di Clifford sono operazioni unitarie su qualsiasi numero di
qubit che possono essere implementate da circuit quantistici con un insieme ristretto di gate, cioè gate Hadamard, gate S
e gate CNOT. Nota che i gate T non sono inclusi, né i gate Toffoli o di Fredkin,
e non solo quei gate non sono inclusi in questo elenco, ma in effetti è impossibile implementare quei gate
usando quelli elencati qui, quindi non sono operazioni di Clifford. Le operazioni di Pauli, d'altra parte,
sono operazioni di Clifford e in particolare possono essere implementate usando sequenze di gate Hadamard e S.
Questo è un modo semplice per definire le operazioni di Clifford, ma non spiega davvero perché siano definite in
questo modo o cosa ci sia di speciale in questa particolare raccolta di gate. Ecco il vero motivo per cui le operazioni di Clifford sono definite in questo
modo: a meno di una fase globale, le operazioni di Clifford a N qubit sono precisamente le operazioni unitarie
che trasformano sempre le operazioni di Pauli in operazioni di Pauli per coniugazione. Per essere più precisi, un'operazione unitaria a N qubit
U è un'operazione di Clifford a meno di un fattore di fase globale se e solo se per ogni operazione di Pauli a N qubit,
coniugare quell'operazione di Pauli per U ci dà più o meno uno volte qualche operazione di Pauli a N qubit
possibilmente diversa. Puoi facilmente verificare che questa proprietà sia vera per i gate Hadamard, i gate S
e i gate CNOT, quindi vale necessariamente per i circuit costruiti con questi gate. Ciò che è più difficile da dimostrare è che vale
nella direzione opposta, ovvero che se ci viene data una particolare operazione unitaria a N qubit U che soddisfa questa
proprietà, allora deve essere possibile implementarla a meno di una fase globale usando solo gate Hadamard, S e CNOT.
Non spiegherò la dimostrazione di questa implicazione, ma è vera e puoi cercarne la dimostrazione se sei
interessato. Le operazioni di Clifford non sono universali per il calcolo quantistico, nel senso che non possiamo eseguire calcoli quantistici arbitrari
usando solo gate Hadamard, S e CNOT. In effetti, per un dato valore di N, ci sono solo un numero finito di
operazioni di Clifford a N qubit, quindi è un insieme discreto di operazioni. Quindi, diversamente da un
insieme universale di gate quantistici, non possiamo approssimare operazioni unitarie arbitrarie con qualsiasi grado di precisione desiderato, e
in effetti eseguire operazioni di Clifford su stati della base standard seguite da misurazioni nella base standard non ci permette
di eseguire calcoli che vanno oltre le possibilità degli algoritmi classici, perché possiamo simulare efficientemente calcoli di questa forma
in modo classico. Questo fatto è noto come teorema di Gottesman-Knill, e la dimostrazione standard di quel teorema è in qualche senso
basata sul formalismo degli stabilizzatori. In particolare, il modo in cui funziona è che possiamo tenere traccia del modo in cui le operazioni di Clifford trasformano le operazioni di Pauli
per coniugazione, il che può essere fatto in modo efficiente, e poi dedurre da ciò cosa i calcoli fanno ai
qubit. Quindi cosa c'entra questo con i codici stabilizzatori? Ebbene, un codice stabilizzatore ci
fornisce uno spazio del codice di una certa dimensione, e abbiamo la libertà di usare quello spazio del codice come vogliamo. Quindi nulla ci obbliga a codificare i
qubit in quello spazio in un modo specifico, ma sarà sempre possibile eseguire una codifica usando un'operazione di Clifford
come encoder. Questo è positivo perché le operazioni di Clifford sono relativamente semplici rispetto alle operazioni unitarie arbitrarie.
Esistono modi per ottimizzarne l'implementazione, che funzionano in modo simile alla dimostrazione del teorema di Gottesman-
Knill, e di conseguenza i circuit per implementarle non devono mai essere troppo
grandi. In particolare, possiamo sempre eseguire una codifica usando un'operazione di Clifford che richiede un numero di gate un po' inferiore al quadratico,
perché questo è vero di ogni operazione di Clifford. Quindi il risultato è che per un dato codice stabilizzatore è sempre
possibile codificare i qubit in modo efficiente usando quel codice, e gli strumenti matematici utili per comprendere le operazioni di Clifford possono aiutare in questo
processo. Ad esempio, ecco un encoder per il codice Steane a 7 qubit: è un'operazione di Clifford e si scopre che
questa non ha nemmeno bisogno di gate S. Per i codici stabilizzatori generali, il rilevamento degli errori funziona nel seguente
modo: come prima, assumeremo di avere generatori dello stabilizzatore a N qubit P1 fino a PR, e sia E un'operazione di Pauli a N qubit
che rappresenta un ipotetico errore su una codifica. Consideriamo solo operazioni di Pauli
come errori, tra l'altro, perché la discretizzazione degli errori funziona nello stesso modo per i codici stabilizzatori arbitrari come per il codice Shore a 9 qubit.
Il modo in cui verifichiamo la presenza di errori è misurare ciascuno dei generatori dello stabilizzatore come
osservabili. Ci sono R generatori dello stabilizzatore, quindi questo significa R risultati dove ognuno è più uno o meno uno,
o un valore binario se preferisci associare zero a più uno e uno a meno uno, e questi R risultati
insieme formano la sindrome, proprio come avevamo per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit quando R era uguale a
due. In generale ci sono tre possibili casi per l'errore E in termini di rilevamento, e sono i seguenti: primo,
potrebbe essere che E sia nello stabilizzatore, nel senso che è possibile generare E dai generatori dello stabilizzatore, o
più in generale potrebbe essere che E sia equivalente a un elemento dello stabilizzatore a meno di una
fase globale. In questo caso E non è davvero un errore, perché non ha alcun effetto sullo spazio del codice oltre a
iniettare eventualmente una fase globale che non ha alcun effetto. Quindi non dobbiamo preoccuparci affatto di errori come questi: qualsiasi
azione non banale che potrebbe avere avviene al di fuori dello spazio del codice, quindi non ci riguarda.
Di maggiore preoccupazione è la possibilità che E non sia nello stabilizzatore nemmeno a meno di una fase globale, ma
ciononostante commuti con ognuno dei nostri generatori dello stabilizzatore. Ricorda che è
l'anticommutazione dell'errore con un generatore dello stabilizzatore che fa comparire un meno uno da qualche parte nella sindrome,
ma questo non accade in questo caso. Quindi questo è un errore che in realtà cambia i vettori nello spazio del codice in modo
non banale, e lo sappiamo perché altrimenti sarebbe proporzionale a un elemento dello stabilizzatore, ma va
non rilevato dal codice. Questo è il caso brutto: abbiamo un errore che potenzialmente sta cambiando
l'informazione quantistica che abbiamo codificato, ma il codice è ignaro di questo fatto. Ad esempio, per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit
XXX rientra in questa categoria. E l'ultima possibilità è che E
anticommuti con almeno uno dei generatori dello stabilizzatore, e questo significa che il codice rileva questo errore perché
otterremo una sindrome con almeno un meno uno da qualche parte, indicando che qualcosa non va e che dovremo provare a correggere questo errore
in qualche modo. Queste sono dunque le possibilità. Come punto di terminologia,
quando ci riferiamo alla distanza di un codice stabilizzatore intendiamo il peso minimo di un'operazione di Pauli che rientra
nella seconda categoria, nel senso che cambia lo spazio del codice in modo non banale ma il codice non
lo rileva. E quando diciamo che un codice stabilizzatore è un codice stabilizzatore [[N,M,D]] usando
doppie parentesi quadre come mostrato sullo schermo, ciò significa che le codifiche hanno lunghezza N qubit, il
codice è in grado di codificare M qubit, quindi lo spazio del codice ha dimensione 2 alla M, e la sua distanza è D. Quindi un errore deve avere
peso D o superiore per cambiare lo stato logico dei qubit codificati senza essere rilevato come
errore. Esamineremo ora il codice Steane a 7 qubit come esempio e determineremo qual è la sua distanza.
Ecco i generatori dello stabilizzatore per questo codice e ricorda che la distanza è il peso minimo di un'operazione di Pauli a N qubit
che commuta con tutti i generatori dello stabilizzatore ma non è essa stessa nello stabilizzatore né
è proporzionale a un elemento dello stabilizzatore. Quello che determineremo è che questo codice ha distanza
tre. Il modo in cui lo determineremo è considerare prima qualsiasi operazione di Pauli con peso al massimo due, e
concluderemo che l'unico modo in cui può commutare con tutti e sei i generatori dello stabilizzatore è essere l'identità, che è sempre un elemento del
stabilizzatore. Supponiamo quindi che le matrici di Pauli possibilmente non-identità che formano questa operazione, che chiameremo
P e Q, appaiano nelle due posizioni più a sinistra. Questo è solo un caso e dobbiamo effettivamente
considerare tutte le altre possibili posizioni per queste matrici di Pauli possibilmente non-identità, ma l'argomentazione è fondamentalmente la stessa per tutte
le posizioni possibili. Ebbene, per ipotesi questa operazione commuta con tutti e sei
i generatori dello stabilizzatore, quindi in particolare commuta con questo e commuta anche con
quest'altro. Q si allinea con la matrice identità in entrambi questi generatori, motivo per cui abbiamo scelto questi due, e abbiamo le matrici
identità nelle cinque posizioni più a destra di questo errore. Concludiamo quindi che P deve commutare sia con X
che con Z, perché altrimenti questo errore anticommuterebbe con uno di questi due generatori. Ma l'unica matrice di Pauli che
commuta sia con X che con Z è l'identità, quindi P deve essere l'identità. Ora che lo sappiamo
possiamo scegliere altri due generatori dello stabilizzatore che hanno una X e una Z nella seconda posizione da sinistra, e possiamo
trarre una conclusione simile su Q. Quindi non c'è modo per un errore di peso al massimo 2 di passare inosservato in questo codice
a meno che non sia la sola operazione identità, che è nello stabilizzatore, quindi in realtà non è
un errore. D'altra parte, ci sono operazioni di Pauli di peso tre che commutano con tutti e sei questi generatori dello stabilizzatore
ma non sono proporzionali a elementi dello stabilizzatore, ed ecco due esempi. Abbiamo quindi concluso che questo
codice ha distanza tre. L'ultima cosa che discuteremo in questa lezione è la correzione degli errori per
i codici stabilizzatori. Come al solito, assumeremo che il nostro codice sia specificato da generatori dello stabilizzatore a N qubit
P1 fino a PR. Iniziamo pensando un po' a tutti i possibili errori che potrebbero
verificarsi. Ci sono 2 alla R possibili sindromi e, come ho menzionato prima nella lezione, queste sindromi partizionano tutte
le possibili operazioni di Pauli a N qubit in insiemi di uguale dimensione, il che significa 4 alla N diviso 2 alla R operazioni di Pauli
per ogni insieme. Quindi quando vediamo una particolare sindrome potrebbe essere che uno qualsiasi di questi 4 alla N diviso 2
alla R errori sia responsabile. Stiamo però sovracontando un po' qui, perché alcuni di questi
errori hanno esattamente lo stesso effetto sullo spazio del codice. In particolare, se abbiamo un errore E e moltiplichiamo E per un qualsiasi
elemento dello stabilizzatore S, otterremo un altro errore che ha esattamente lo stesso effetto nello spazio del codice di E.
Questi sono errori equivalenti. Lo stabilizzatore ha 2 alla R elementi e se teniamo conto di questo troviamo
che per ogni sindrome ci sono 4 alla N meno R classi di equivalenza di errori che avrebbero potuto causare quella
sindrome. E ciò significa che a meno che R non sia uguale a N, nel qual caso abbiamo uno spazio del codice monodimensionale e
quindi non possiamo codificare nessun qubit, non sarà possibile correggere ogni errore che possiamo rilevare. Invece,
quello che dobbiamo fare è scegliere solo un'operazione di correzione per ogni sindrome, sperando di correggere solo una classe di errori equivalenti.
Come dovremmo scegliere quale correzione eseguire per ogni sindrome? Una strategia naturale è scegliere
l'operazione di Pauli di peso minimo che causa la sindrome che misuriamo, con l'idea che le operazioni di Pauli di peso inferiore
rappresentino spiegazioni più probabili per quella sindrome. Questa potrebbe non essere effettivamente la
scelta migliore per alcuni modelli di rumore, e un'altra strategia naturale è calcolare in qualche modo l'errore più probabile che causa la
data sindrome. Ma per ora considereremo solo la strategia in cui proviamo a correggere gli errori selezionando l'operazione di Pauli di peso minimo che causa la
sindrome. Per un codice stabilizzatore di distanza D, questa strategia ci permetterà sempre di correggere errori di peso strettamente
inferiore alla metà di D, ovvero di peso al massimo (D-1)/2, e spiegherò brevemente il perché.
Questo mostrerà ad esempio che il codice Steane a 7 qubit può correggere qualsiasi errore di Pauli di peso uno, e per la
discretizzazione degli errori ciò significa che, proprio come il codice Shore a 9 qubit, il codice Steane può correggere un
errore arbitrario su un qubit. Ecco come funziona: considera che questo cerchio rappresenta tutte le possibili operazioni di Pauli
che producono la sindrome tutti-più-uno, che è la sindrome che suggerisce che non si sono verificati errori
e che tutto va bene. Tra queste operazioni abbiamo elementi dello stabilizzatore, o davvero
operazioni proporzionali a elementi dello stabilizzatore, e abbiamo anche errori non banali che cambiano lo spazio del codice in qualche modo ma non vengono
rilevati dal codice. E sappiamo per definizione di distanza che ogni operazione di Pauli in questa categoria deve avere peso almeno
D, poiché D è definito come il peso minimo di queste operazioni. Abbiamo anche operazioni di Pauli
che causano la comparsa di altre sindromi, e potremmo considerare ogni sindrome a turno se vogliamo, ma qui stiamo semplicemente immaginando
che sia apparsa una tale sindrome S. Ora immagina che E sia un errore in questa
categoria con peso strettamente inferiore alla metà della distanza D. Non sappiamo necessariamente che sia
l'operazione di peso minimo in questo cerchio, quindi sia C l'operazione di peso minimo in questo insieme, o una di esse nel caso in cui ci sia un pareggio.
Quindi potrebbe essere che C sia uguale a E o eventualmente no, ma poiché C ha
peso minimo, sappiamo che non può avere peso maggiore del peso di E, dato che C è anch'esso nell'insieme
e ha peso minimo. Quindi l'operazione di correzione C deve avere peso strettamente inferiore alla metà di
D. Cosa succede se applichiamo questa correzione C a qualunque sia diventato il nostro stato dopo che si è verificato l'errore E?
La risposta è che lo stato che otteniamo è C moltiplicato E applicato alla codifica originale, perché prima
moltiplichiamo per E che era l'errore e poi moltiplichiamo per C per provare a correggerlo, e questo prodotto deve essere nello
stabilizzatore o proporzionale a un elemento dello stabilizzatore. Ecco perché: primo, poiché E e C ci danno la
stessa sindrome, C moltiplicato E deve darci la sindrome tutti-più-uno. Questo perché per un dato
generatore dello stabilizzatore, o C ed E commutano entrambi con quel generatore, o entrambi anticommutano: deve essere lo stesso per
entrambi perché le sindromi sono le stesse. E se ci pensi un momento, ciò implica che C moltiplicato E deve
commutare con tutti i generatori dello stabilizzatore. E infine, C moltiplicato E deve essere
nello stabilizzatore, perché il suo peso non può essere maggiore della somma dei pesi di C e E, quindi il suo peso
è strettamente inferiore a D, e ciò significa che correggiamo con successo E, perché applicare E seguito da C non fa nulla allo
spazio del codice. Ottimo, ma c'è un solo problema, ed è che per i codici stabilizzatori
in generale è un problema computazionalmente difficile calcolare l'operazione di peso minimo che causa una data
sindrome, e in effetti questo vale anche per i codici classici, che in questo contesto possiamo pensare come codici stabilizzatori
in cui appaiono solo matrici identità e matrici Pauli Z come fattori tensoriali all'interno dei generatori dello stabilizzatore.
Quindi, a differenza della fase di codifica, le operazioni di Clifford non vengono in nostro soccorso questa volta, e l'unica soluzione ragionevole
è scegliere codici specifici per i quali le buone correzioni possono essere calcolate in modo efficiente. Non c'è una ricetta per
questo: in poche parole, progettare codici stabilizzatori di questo tipo fa parte dell'arte
della progettazione di codici quantistici. Questo è un buon punto in cui fermarsi per questa lezione. Spero che tu ti unirai a me
per la prossima lezione, in cui daremo un'occhiata ad alcune costruzioni specifiche di codici quantistici, inclusi codici che illustrano l'arte della progettazione di codici quantistici
in modo abbastanza spettacolare. Arrivederci per ora.